hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I oh
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well indica que no
ethics book 10 Aristotle revisits the
life of pleasure as a candidate for the
happy life II and he discusses this in
terms of what we translate generally as
amusements the greek term for that is
idea and it's coming from the word for a
child Pais and it means the sort of
things that children indulgent and
engage in and enjoy but it also
encompasses the things that adults also
enjoy that children perhaps don't enjoy
but are along the same lines so when we
talk about play that might be another
great way to translate idea is plenty or
enjoyment what is the actual value of
this and does that fit into the the
happy life so Aristotle says when we're
thinking about happiness itself we want
to attend to activities that are engaged
in and chosen for their own sake because
if we're if we're thinking about things
that we do in order to get something
else like for example going to work now
might enjoy going to work but one of the
great tests for that would be are you
going to keep doing it after you win the
lottery you know not just so you can get
out of the house but so that you you can
derive the kind of enjoyment that you
want to get for a good light or if you
won the lottery would you call up your
boss and say that's it for me there are
a lot of activities even in our
day-to-day life that we engage in for
their own sakes some of them are kind of
mindless if you're walking down the
street when's landing and somebody says
what are you doing that whistling for
you you probably don't have much of an
answer so well I just I just AM and then
they might say well why are you doing
that so well I like to I enjoy that
somebody else might say well I don't
enjoy your whistling so knock it off but
they're not participating in your
amusement in that case maybe they come
up with their own song so there's a lot
of things that we do for their their own
sake not because they are going to
produce or to lead to something else
great example of this in our own time
would be watching shows on television
around your computer through say Netflix
or Hulu or cable provider or any of
these sorts of things you sit there and
you watch a show and if somebody comes
in and says what are you doing you say
i'm watching this show and they ask you
well why are you watching that show
generally what they're saying is why are
you watching that show instead of doing
something else that I expect you should
be doing such as folding the laundry or
doing your homework something along
those lines getting outside and
exercising but if your answer with
something like well I'm doing this for
my own betterment you know that's the
sort of Dodge that we often have i'm
watching this show because i'm doing
research for a paper that i'm writing
yeah that's that's
I'm doing it's quite legitimate
Aristotle thanks in a lot of cases just
to watch a show in order to watch a show
because you like watching this show now
because you're actually going to write
something about it not because you're
drawing valuable life lessons from it
although some shows our rather de tactic
that was a big thing back in 70s and 80s
and 90s if you think about shows back
then amusements are things that we do
for their own sake because we enjoy them
if you go to the festival and listen to
some music or go to the amusement park
and ride on some rides and if somebody
says well why are you doing that the
answer is I like doing that I enjoy
doing that so now the big question is
how does that fit in with happiest our
amusements what make us happy and like I
put here many people Aristotle thinks is
the case consider those who get to enjoy
amusements at least to the degree that
they want you to be living the happy
life so most of us if not all of us
enjoy something or another and most of
us get to indulge in it to a certain
extent but we have lots of other
constraints upon our time or our our
property or wealth or income so you know
it's not as if you could just watch
Netflix for the rest of your life I mean
theoretically you probably could at this
point because there's not content in
there that you could just keep watching
and watching and watching and never stop
never actually produce anything other
than the activity of sitting on the
couch and watching Netflix or I suppose
you could lay in your back and do it as
well but most of us have to hold down
job you know we have to earn some some
living that that puts the food on the
table puts the roof over our head puts
all the other things that we need
clothing that into internalized so a lot
of people think of the life where you
could just engage in amusements all the
time probably because you're
independently wealthy or you're super
well connected
to be the best life and Aristotle says
that's not the case and he points out a
few things right off the bat some of
these amusements can actually be quite
harmful they can lead us to ignore our
health they can lead us to ignore
property i would say that another thing
they can often lead us to ignore or two
to put less work into is our careers and
our jobs you know for a student for
example it could be fun to play video
games and I've known quite a few
students who ended up dropping out
because they couldn't keep themselves
from playing video games when they were
supposed to be studying and then we come
to me and they say I am you know a video
game addiction I said well you're going
to find a way to break it because you're
not going to be able to be a student
successfully do the work of a student
and make progress and indulge in video
games anywhere from six to ten hours a
day it's just not possible somebody you
could say the same thing about downhill
skiing you know or figure sting or
throwing dice or whatever you want all
these things are amusements and they're
good in a certain range aerosol is not
knocking them but when they become the
central feature of our life they'll
often leads to to ignore things that are
you know very important for us and to
its to our detriment that we ignore the
relationships would another would be
another good that perhaps we be lessened
by focusing too much on amusements so
Aristotle gives a number of different
arguments for why amusements are not
happiness or the best life why a life
filled with those is not that one of the
things that he considers that's quite
interesting if you think about a culture
is the role of what we often translate
as powerful people the actual green word
here is do not stay aware that we get
dynasty from so think about people who
hand money in their family for several
generations they were born to money to
parents who were born to money they live
a very different kind of life than the
rest of us do at least most of them do
in part because they're not quite so
worried about the sorts of things that
we're worried about and because it opens
up so many other opportunities and
allows them to take certain things for
granted well you know here in Wisconsin
when I get her up there was a very
strong class distinction between those
who could afford to go across to go
downhill skiing which entailed having
lift ticket and all that sort of stuff
and you have like a tall sticker for
each time that you went and you can tell
who went downhill skiing walk they have
a lot of stickers and then the rest of
us slums who went on a cross-country
skiing cross-country skiing at a very
little entry fee you would do it in
public parks you didn't have to pay
anything once you have your skis the
only real risk was of outgrowing your
boots and he was you know two different
kinds of activities right so the people
who have a jew nastya seem to value
amusements they get to spend a lot of
time you know hanging out and you know
eating nice food and going to advance
and being seen here and there so maybe
that's that's really the case what about
powerful people they seem to want people
around who are actually experts in
amusements they want the people who are
the great cooks for example to be the
great chefs to be cooks for them they
want to bring in the jugglers for their
kids birthday party and so on and so on
right every someone says well powerful
people there's they're not any smarter
than the rest of us it don't provide a
particularly good or edifying example he
says bricks princes and potentates this
way this translation goes on a good
evidence virtue and intelligence which
are the sources of human higher
activities don't depend upon the
possession of power this is the case we
often see this elites we attribute to
them qualities that they don't have to
not any smarter than the rest of us
they're not any better than the rest of
us as I forget exactly said if the rich
are in fact different from the rest of
us they have more money and similarly
with those who have more power or more
juice more connections so he says if
those persons having no taste your pure
and liberal pleasure have recourse to
the pleasures of the body we must not on
that account suppose that bodily
pleasures are the more desirable
children for example think that certain
things are very pleasurable and they are
for children you know what you know if
you offer a child the opportunity to eat
candy all day long that's great for them
if you let them play video games all day
long they will it'll do that that
doesn't mean that those things are
actually good or better they could be
good to a limited extent but they're not
they're not better so powerful people
the fact that they often seek a life of
me has been sometimes perhaps as a
compensation for how much responsibility
they after their um that's not
particularly helpful the next thing that
I ever saw has to say is that an
amusement is really something for our
leisure time it says isn't it kind of
weird to think that the whole point of
all this activity that we engage in
would just be to have a vacation and
have a bit of leisure time you know the
time that we get off of work work like a
dog so then you can as I say work hard
play hard right there's something
missing to that kind of life Aristotle
things and and we do see in fact people
live like that and then after a Wilder
like this isn't really that satisfying I
need something that is a better way of
living something that has more
meaningfulness to it not just parties
all the time or vacations are going to
travel here and there that's because
it's in a certain way a child which form
of life it's it's a not having yet
mature and I think in our
society our own consumer society we have
entire generations of adult children who
never really learned how to lit it white
like adults and have those sorts of
pleasures that adults can have in
meaningful activity rather than just in
amusement that's part of my pop culture
has become such an obsession a little
bit editorializing there but it's good
to bring Aristotle up to date another
thing that Aristotle says is that the
life of virtue which key things to be
the happy life or one of the types of
happy life is in fact a life of what he
calls serious purpose and doesn't
consist in although it doesn't rule out
amusements so if we want the life that
really is a happy life well then we have
to be serious a good bit of the time
what else so what only the activity of
the higher faculty our intellect are our
rational faculties it may in fact be
part of what contributes to amusement if
you think about joking around sometimes
jokes can be quite a intellectual it did
often tend to be dry in that case but a
lot of what we do with our minds is not
just joking around or try to figure out
how to make things Pleasant for people
we try to stay solve problems real
problems and there's a kind of pleasure
that comes with genuine problem solving
tan tackling a real life challenge there
is better than doing it in some sim game
you know a lot of the games that are out
there now are quite advanced and they
sometimes require you to become quite a
bureaucrat at that point they often
become less fun but they're detached
from from reality of their they're not
really engaging the higher faculty the
way that real life questions and
problems and conundrums do the final
thing that Aristotle points out
I'm not sure that we are necessarily
going to endorse this honor % it is that
slaves enjoy amusements slaves meaning
actual slaves people who are unfree they
enjoy amusements just like everybody
else we're talking here about your
private amusements that they're able to
do at their own time and public
amusements that were put on for them
like games festivals you know we would
think now in our own time about sporting
events although those are often cost
money you know free concerts all these
sorts of things so if we don't say that
slaves are actually living a happy life
so the slaves are spending their time
trying to get these ones will oftentimes
they'll work just so they can have a
little bit of amusement then why would
we consider that to be the happy life so
here someone's not sending amusement is
bad he is saying that it's not the
fundamental goal or the orientation of
the happy life